welcome to Germany land of the autobahn
where there's no speed limit where
everything always runs on time or so you
thought but look a little closer and you
can see a decade of austerity it's
starting to take its toll
forty percent of all bridges and a fifth
of the motorway network are said to be
in critical condition some say a bit
more spent on this could be the answer
not just to Germany's problems but also
the whole eurozone
but talk to the mittelstand the
country's manufacturing base and they
are more worried about how difficult it
is to sell their goods abroad
isabelle horns family has owned her
company a glass display cabinet maker
for a century what times are getting
tougher when our business is a slow
moving business and even though the
economy is picking up in some thousand
European countries it will take a while
TV feel the positive effects different
countries affect us what we have to do
is then to try to find another market to
go somewhere else where the economy is
just picking up and now experts worry
that the crisis may be coming back to
haunt the eurozone no I mean we see the
first signs that some type of euro
crisis is coming back I don't nobody
knows but I don't expect you know that
we'll go back to the heydays in 2012 but
obviously since the recovery is stalling
and since we find out that the ESP
cannot basically pull the ECB out of
this rat on its own obviously there will
be more inviting and markets will start
to wonder
the mood is uneasy here in Frankfort
where those markets are based like
Germany France has also avoided
recession but it only managed half a
percent of growth in the past year Italy
hasn't even achieved a single quarter of
growth for more than three years every
now and then they still jealous glances
in this direction when you think of the
21st century German economy the image
you will be conjuring up is something
like this is efficient it financially
extremely advanced but this is a country
which never forgets its past whether
that's hyperinflation that happened the
1920s or whether indeed it's the recent
crisis that happened in the eurozone so
while Europe faces its own problems at
the moment a lot of people are looking
towards Germany to try to do things to
sort it out the reality though is there
are no simple answers here the thing is
it's simply not very Germanic to go out
and spend like there's no tomorrow a lot
of credit card and they like like the
cash the money I like the feeling there
a mother yeah a lot of people who do not
have as much money but they still like
to spend it on good stuff yeah but in
general I think German people do not
like to spend that much money yet in a
country which keeps shrines to as
manufacturers this one for Karl Benz
inventor of the car there is a standard
answer export your way out of trouble
Germany's problem is that this time
around no one's buying it at Conway Sky
News in Frankfurt